dating in general
um
you tweeted are you based in Boston and
single question mark and then you
pointed to a startup singles night
sponsored by smile dating app because I
mean this is jumping around a little bit
but because since you mentioned
um
can AI help solve this uh dating love
problem what do you think this problem
of connection
that is part of the human condition can
AI help that you yourself are in the
search affirming
maybe that's what I should affirm like
build an AI build an AI that finds love
I think
I think there must be a science behind
that first moment you meet a person and
you either have chemistry or you don't
right like you I guess that was the
question I was asking would you put it
brilliantly is that a science or an art
ooh I think there are like there's
actual chemicals that get exchanged when
two people meet I don't know about that
I like how you're changing yeah yeah
changing your mind as we're describing
it but it feels that way right but it's
what science shows us is sometimes we
can explain with the rigor the things
that feel like magic right
so maybe you can remove all the magic
maybe it's like I honestly think like I
said like Goodreads should be a dating
app which like books I I wonder I wonder
if you look at just like books or
content you've consumed I mean that's
essentially what YouTube does when it
does recommend a recommendation if you
just look at your footprint of content
consumed
if there's an overlap but maybe
interesting difference with an overlap
that some I'm sure this is a machine
learning problem that's solvable
like this person is very likely to be
not only there to be chemistry in the
short term but a good lifelong partner
to grow together I bet you it's a good
machine learning problem we just need
the data let's do it well
two of us that they're ought to be ought
to be a learning algorithm that can
ingest all this data and basically say I
think the following 10 people would be
interesting connections for you right
um and and so smile dating app kind of
took one particular angle which is humor
it matches People based on their humor
Styles which is one of the main
ingredients of a successful relationship
like if you meet somebody and they can
make you laugh like that's a good thing
and if you develop like internal jokes
like inside jokes and you're bantering
like that's fun yeah so I think yeah
yeah definitely definitely but yeah
that's the uh
the number of and the rate of inside
joke generation
you could probably measure that and then
optimize it over the first few days
right and then we're just turning this
into a machine learning problem I love
it
uh but for somebody like you who's
exceptionally successful and busy
um
is there
is there science to that aspect of
dating is it tricky is there a device
you can give oh my God I'd give the
worst advice well I can tell you like I
have a spreadsheet I'm spreadsheet
that's great is that a good or a bad
thing do you regret the spreadsheet uh
well I don't know what's the name of
this spreadshe Is It Love
the date track dating tracker it's very
like love tracker yeah and there's a
rating system I'm sure yeah there's like
weights and stuff and it's too close to
home oh is it do you also I don't have a
spreadsheet but I would now that you say
it it seems like a good idea oh no
uh turning into Data
um yeah I do wish that somebody else had
a spreadsheet about me hmm if you know
if it was a cut like like I said like
you said uh convert collect a lot of
data about us in a way that's privacy
preserving that I own the data I can
control it and then use that data to
find not I mean not just romantic love
but uh collaborators friends all that
kind of stuff it seems like the data is
there right uh the that's the problem
social networks are trying to solve but
I think they're doing a really poor job
even Facebook tried to get into a dating
app uh business and I think there's so
many components to running a successful
the company that connects human beings
and part of that is
you know having Engineers they care
about the human side right as you know
extremely well it's not it's not easy to
find those but but you don't also don't
want just people that care about the
human they also have to be a good
Engineers so it's like you have to find
this this this beautiful mix and for
some reason just empirically speaking
it's it people have not done a good job
of that of building companies like that
and it must mean that it's a difficult
problem to solve dating apps it seems
difficult Okay Cupid tender all those
kind of stuff
they seem
to find of course they work but they
seem
to not work as well as I would imagine
is possible like right with data
wouldn't you be able to find better
human connection it's like arranged
marriages on steroids right right
arranged by Machine learning algorithms
arranged by Machine learning algorithm
but but not a superficial one I think a
lot of the dating apps out there are
just so superficial they're just
matching on like high level criteria
that aren't ingredients for successful
partnership
but you know what's missing though too I
don't know how to fix that the
Serendipity piece of it like how do you
engineer Serendipity like this random
like chance encounter and then you fall
in love with the person like I don't
know how a dating app can can do that so
it has to be a little bit of Randomness
Maybe
every 10th match is just a you know
yeah somebody that the algorithm
wouldn't have necessarily recommended
but it's it allows for a little bit of
well it can also you know it can also
trick you into thinking it sounded to be
by like somehow showing you a tweet of a
person
that he thinks you'll match well with
but do it accidentally as part of
another search right and like you just
notice it like and then you get it you
go down a rabbit hole and you connect
them in outside the app to like so you
connect with this person outside the
house somehow so it's just it creates
that moment of meeting
um of course you have to think of from
an app perspective how you can turn that
into a business but I think ultimately a
business that helps people find love in
any way like that's what Apple was about
create products that people love right
that's beautiful I mean that's you got
to make money somehow if you help people
fall in love
personally with the product find
self-love or another human being you're
gonna make money yeah you're going to
figure out a way to make money
um I just feel like the dating apps
often will optimize
for something else than love it's a
single social networks they optimize for
engagement right as opposed to like a
deep meaningful connection
um that's ultimately grounded in like
personal growth you as a human being
growing and all that kind of stuff